I was just uh thank you
I was just with my niece I love babies
but you know it's better than a baby is
uh not having a baby I get drunk all the
time I sleep in I confidently walk back
to overheated cars I mean it's a good
life
my sister's calling the baby a miracle
and I play along but it's a bit much
miracle we never call adults miracles
we're doing way cooler stuff I just have
a baby and we're like it's a miracle
then it grows up and were like never
mind
two people boned it's not miraculous
winning the lottery that's a miracle
you'd never win the Mega Millions
jackpot and be like should we keep it
I love kids I go I tried to join the Big
Brothers program I was rudely rejected
but I gave it a shot they don't get my
humor I made to the third round of the
woman was like what's a bad example of a
Big Brother and I thought she would
laugh if I was like you mean like a
child molester
she did not laugh
she said we were looking for like
impatient okay I thought we were playing
high stakes she was like what are you
gonna bring to the Big Brother program
and I said patience because that's the
opposite of pedophilia the willingness
to wait that one's not for everybody I
understand yeah I'm a good person I tell
some dark jokes you know he's a clean
comedian you guys might love Bill Cosby
that guy family-friendly I love the kids
I'll play with my niece I'm trying to
make her laugh cuz she's crying and my
sisters like you got to let her cry
she's at that age now if you interrupt
she becomes dependent that's crazy we do
that the babies you can't even do that
to adults if you came to my apartment
and my girlfriend was hysterically
crying I can't be like it's cool I'm
training her so we're gonna nip this in
the bud early on
because I don't like her feelings I
choose the wrong women I was talking to
my therapist and he said you tend to
pursue damaged people and then try to
help them and I was like you too you
women try to change us every day try to
change thing I'm not trying to change
I'm trying to improve you know what
having a girlfriend feels like you know
the thing in your iPhone that's always
asked and if you want an update that's
what it feels like the whole time just
all day hey do you want to get better
and all day I'm like remind me later go
to change us you're not Billy Joel song
I love you just the way you are a woman
would never write a song like that
if Billy Joel wore a woman that song
will be called you are my project and
we'll see what this goes I just had a
breakup can you guys tell by my tongue
she broke up with me and then asked me
to take her back and then curveball
broke up with me again you know what
that feels like that feels like you're
on a plane that's going down and then
somehow you land safely and then you die
in the cab ride home the good news is
the good news is she texts me every day
so I'm still not over so that's the good
news
I miss you I'm like that's one of the
downfalls of breaking up with someone
you don't get to see them as often thank
god jobs don't look like that can you
imagine getting fire than two weeks
later your boss is like I'm sad well I'm
happy because it's your fault
it's hard to break up there's one good
thing about a breakup it really makes
you appreciate rap lyrics because when I
was in a relationship I'd hear it I'd be
like that's a generalization okay but
now I hear it I'm like it's true these
hoes are not loyal but you Evan are
amazing you are I'll tell you why
because you can fake an orgasm but you
can't fake a good mood you can tell me
I'm the best you've ever had you can't
smile once at a family picnic where are
those Oh My gods when I need them thank
you so much guys
[Applause]
you